so Krampus I don't know if it's Krampus
or crumpets I'm gonna call it crumpets
if you think it's Krampus and you think
Krampus is wrong and I'm pronouncing it
wrong we'll blame it on the accent that
I guess I have because that's how I roll
my letters
so Krampus is a movie that's ultimately
the merging of Christmas and Halloween
which right there that premise is going
to get some praise from me that only was
I looking forward to this movie but I
was looking forward to it because of
that simple fact everyone loves the
merging of Christmas and Halloween we
all know the fable of Christmas on
Christmas st. Nicholas comes Santa Claus
comes and he brings Joey and he brings
presents and he gives and he's wonderful
this movie is the other side of that
fable the other side of that coin that's
right the shadow of st. Nicholas the
dark entity known as Krampus is coming
to this family's home is basically bring
terror so now this family has to hold
off this really evil cloaked horned
thing known as Krampus and all those
evil minions who were working with him
we were trying to also kill this family
who look like all the jump scares from
five nights at Freddy's and at first the
setup was going pretty good you see this
family they're a pretty normal family
you know pretty par for the course you
like rock Krampus is going to terrorize
these people I feel so bad for that then
the in-laws come and he's pretty much
Eddie and his family from Christmas
vacation with none of the likeability no
seriously these people were [ __ ]
they were dicks they were [ __ ] and I
just the entire time I was a guy I want
crumpets to kill you people which is a
bummer because I feel like a movie like
this should be one bad kid brings
crumpets and now all the good people
have to suffer those consequences but in
this one it's reversed is one good kid
brings crumpets and now five [ __ ]
have to suffer the consequences and
you're completely fine with that you
shouldn't be it takes away some of the
tension because you're like you
shouldn't be rooting for crumpets to win
you need to root for the family to get
away from crumpet you root for half the
family the other half of the family by
die this movie does a pretty good job at
making it feel claustrophobic they can't
really get out of their house because
this huge Blizzard has rolled in they
can't go anywhere the power's out
Krampus is coming it kind of felt like a
Stephen King story at that point for
some odd reason I've just known King
does that where it's like Oh
everything's cut off you guys are
isolated in this pocket and now bad [ __ ]
is coming but the movie does start to
fall apart it's just going through the
motions that you know we're coming it's
like oh yeah crumpets is bad they're
going to try to escape who the
it really is horror movie 101 just
playing out right in front of you it was
really cool when you first see Krampus
you know and he's on the roof and he's
howling and he's running along the
rooftop he reminded me to the howling
man from The Twilight Zone did that howl
was terrifying but to its core it's a
home invasion movie with cookie
gingerbread men in horrible clown boxes
that's also one of the faults it
concentrated on the minions so much that
Corinne Crump has showed up you were
glad he showed up but he just didn't
show up enough I know in some movies I
always grab like oh they showed the big
baddie way too much well this is one of
those movies that could have shown him a
little more he should have actually been
the main antagonist it should have been
him trying to get into the house it
should have been him walking along the
rooftops it should've been him coming
down the chimney every time the minions
could have been a fine accent to that
concept but really make crumpets the
star the movie is called crumpets a
movie he's not called crumpets as
minions and I really feel like this
movie was trying to hold back in trying
to be pg-13 I don't know if they film
the movie to be a rated R movie and I
cut it back to be pg-13 or if they
genuinely had a lady yell at the little
clown in the box give me back my kid you
effort or fricker or whatever they said
they wanted to say [ __ ] they wanted to
drop that right there but they just
couldn't because it was pg-13 I just
feel like it was a classic case of that
pg-13 rating is holding the movie back
because in the end Krampus was simple
entertainment which I knew crumpets
would be simple entertainment but it is
as simple as it possibly gets for this
premise judging by how cool that premise
is I mean it's an evil Santa Clause
entity it's the evil part of Christmas
the evil part of Saint Nick is coming
it's kind of wasted because you don't
get to see how bad this thing is because
you barely get to see crumpets at all
it's a pretty average home invasion
horror movie some things were done well
some things were not in the end you walk
out of Krampus thinking to yourself I'm
sure crumpets would be a bit better if I
were drunk yeah now it's a party [ __ ]
and drunk on Christmas I'm on the
naughty list here comes the Krampus
crevasse German I guess I sound German
whatever right so Krampus have you seen
it what did you think about it or what's
your favorite Halloween or Christmas
movie I don't know what you want to ask
so I'm asking both whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more